neither of us owe anybody anything
except like respect I respect her a lot
no one ever should be spoken to in the
manner that I've seen Haley Bieber and
Selena Gomez pretty much broke the
internet last month squashing rumors
that there's beef between them I respect
her there's no drama personally and over
the weekend they did it again posing it
up for this snap together I think it was
the right decision yep that's Haley and
Selena all smiles hugging and getting
cozy at the Academy Museum Gala in La
it's awesome Azores tells ET that the
two wanted to show the world that
there's no beef or bad feelings between
them anymore quote they've both moved on
and are happy in their own lives it's
like I want them to know it's okay so
how does Haley's hubby Justin Bieber
feel about his wife and his ex mending
fences well another source tells E.T
that he's happy they can all move on and
that it can be peaceful between everyone
he's a good kid he's a good part and uh
I love him of course this all comes just
two weeks after the model got candid on
the call her daddy podcast about all the
bullying she's faced from fans of both
her husband and his very famous ex over
allegations that she came between them a
lot of the hate and the perpetuation
comes from like oh you stole him and I
guess maybe that just comes from like
the fact that they wished that like he
had ended up with someone else and
that's fine like you can wish that all
you want but that's just not the case
when him and I ever started like hooking
up he was not ever in a relationship
ever at any point it's not my character
to
mess with someone's relationship I would
just never do that I was raised better
than that and shortly after that the
only murders in the building star
addressed the hate she's been seeing
online calling it vile and disgusting
all I have to say is it's incredibly
ironic that I would release something
that is all about kind words because
that's exactly what I want that's it
words matter
truly matter
so
it ain't coming from me
and I just want all of you to know that
I hope that you understand that this is
much bigger than anything else
[Music]